we have some very very good news to
report about the five year old boy who
was thrown from a third-floor balcony at
Minnesota's Mall of America back in
April the family of the boy who is
identified only as Landon posted this
message on GoFundMe yesterday it said we
are pleased to share that our son
completed his inpatient rehabilitation
and is now home the boy suffered
significant head trauma and broken bones
and needed multiple surgeries when he
was tossed nearly forty feet to the
ground by a complete stranger
the Landon will now begin outpatient
rehabilitation this is such a tough
story there's a quote from the family it
talks about how they're rejoicing in the
Lord's blessing to our family given what
happened to little landon italy medical
procedures they say the man who take
your children from that i'm somebody
just walking by and picking you up and
throwing you over the bunker the man who
did it
Emmanuel Aranda pleaded guilty to one
count of attempted premeditated murder
he actually planned to do this sentenced
to 19 years that's right